oh wait
Miss Clarissa I'm gonna tell you girl in
that dress you looking to buy this sweet
as a field full of honeysuckle after a
spring rain shower
how do you do it girl that ass though
what was that what was what what you
just said to her oh well I was just
following y'all leave no you wasn't you
was being all heavy-handed with it man
you got to be subtle
subtle exactly you gotta be subtle you
want to talk to them ladies I can do
that
Mr Nice
they're the way that dress is Flowing
you look like a mountain creek after the
spring thaw simply refreshing what is
Young
secret the way that dress fitting on you
got them titties popping out